Lynn Yellen has been rolling through
bill for almost two hours
the Chinese performer is merciless with
his own body
this group is quietly inhibiting the
dynamic flow of pedestrian traffic
everywhere visitors to the city are
confronted with the human form
performers in the midst of Beals public
spaces living sculptures
we want people to see our bodies moving
in public urban space we want people to
come and like really look at public
space and see it differently with these
bodies with these dancing bodies these
moving bodies these steel bodies
sculptures made up of human bodies have
been integrated into the city's
architecture they lead the eye of the
beholder to places that usually don't
attract much attention
developed by Austrian choreographer
Villa Donna the project is called bodies
in urban spaces
it's give me that home team for me it's
about finding positions that somehow
seize your attention and you need the
power of humanity to do that calling
attention to our very fragile bodies is
also important to me the main shows a
human being was on the one hand very
flexible and able to adjust juxtaposed
with the hard unyielding architecture of
the city Donna takes a playful approach
to the urban world he has a good eye for
cityscape locations that can be turned
into backdrops for friction and conflict
the choreographers set up the route the
performance takes weeks ago
the final form a sculpture takes depends
on the artistic abilities of the
performers that Donna has cast for each
location and Estella the eight
performers at this location correspond
to the eight cubes
they're lying crosswise diagonally to
the stairs and the solidity of the cube
which is a very static element
the choreographer rolled out the project
for the first time eight years ago it
has since appeared in many cities in
Europe the US and Asia certificate
webosphere we took around three or four
years and during this time we fine-tuned
the format and all its elements that's
why it took so much time it's had to
keep a halt but now the work is finished
and it can be performed in different
urban contexts I'd love to take it to
China or Africa that would be
interesting maybe we will I freaked out
Akina gamed as well
nothing to a sound effect come to
living sculptures that disperse after
just a few minutes and reappear in a new
post somewhere else groups of spectators
follow the route to the city seeing it
with fresh eyes I find it very
interesting because they are giving life
to spaces that we normally don't pay
attention to I find it very impressive
because it blends into the city so well
although the clothes also make it very
colorful I like to play on architecture
the buildings and shapes also the
flexibility of the performance and the
energy that it gives to the spectators
ed then I don't you forget
excerpts from 50 years of performance
art on the streets of Biel and when the
performances blend seamlessly into the
urban environment the lines between art
and everyday life vanish